je voudrais embrasser le chaos
on voit souvent le chaos comme quelque
chose d'extérieur à nous quelque chose
qui est une menace quelque chose de
désordonné quelque chose qui vient nous
perturber dans l'ordre nos de nos vies
en réalité pour l'avoir étudiée je
considère que c'est la source de tous
ces petits hasards
c'est la source de toutes les
opportunités qui se présentent face à
nous c'est vraiment là l'origine de tous
les petits hasard à côté desquels on
passe si on cherche à trop le contrôle
et on peut montrer ça de façon assez
simple il y a plein de petites décisions
plein de choix qui ont été faits qui
vous amène ici aujourd'hui la machine
cerveau vous avez faire des choix
certains n'ont pas fait les seychois là
et ne se retrouvent pas là ici il ya
quelques jours votre cerveau a pris des
décisions a pris la décision de prendre
le ticket de de prendre deux voitures de
venir jusqu'ici
et aujourd'hui on est réuni cette petite
machine cerveau ça va pas être évident
de la simuler dans son entier on va
prendre plus simple on va prendre tout
simplement un pendule lui l'a pas le
choix il est accroché à sa base est il
aussi en bas à droite à gauche à droite
à gauche mais il suffit de rajouter un
tout petit paramètres juste une tige en
bas juste une et d'un seul coup ça
devient beaucoup plus riches
il faut savoir que nous mêmes nous
sommes constitués de cent mille
milliards de cellules chacune basé sur
c'est sur ces dynamiques l'a donc ou ne
faut pas considérer que ce chaos il est
en dehors de nous il est vraiment en
chacune de nos cellules en chacune de
nos particules
il est même à la base de ce qui fait le
le vivant pour regarder justement ces
dynamiques chaotique
vu de l'extérieur c'est vraiment j'y
comprends rien qu'est ce qui fait que ça
va en haut c'est quoi la règle qu'est ce
qui fait que ça va en bas c'est quoi la
logique pourquoi trois fois en bas
pourquoi une fois en haut on se pose
tout le temps c'est pourquoi on voudrait
la raison la raison unique
cette raison on peut la voir où ce
mécanisme plus tôt on peut le voir en le
projetant dans l'espace en trois
dimensions d'un seul coup ce n'est plus
à droite à gauche qu'on ne comprend pas
c'est une magnifique structure qui en
effet à deux axes de points centraux au
milieu une infinité de fibres qui sont
hissés infiniment proches les unes des
autres ce qui fait que si on se trompe
un tout petit peu de fibres à un instant
on n'ira pas à gauche on ira à droite
suffit d'entendre peut-être le chant
d'un oiseau il suffit d'avoir une idée
qui se présentent à tel endroit pour que
finalement l'orientation de sa vie
change
et c'est d'ailleurs ce comme souvent
comme ça qui est présenté le le chaos ce
battement d'aile du papillon
là vous le voyez ce sont ces fibres qui
sont tissés je parle de fragilité de
sensibilité en effet si on prend deux
points qui sont extrêmement proches
qu'on les laisse évoluer
on voit qu'au départ ils se suivent
comme deux amis mais petit à petit se
séparent et ils reprennent leur
autonomie c'est bien cette fragilité
mais le paradoxe que résoudre ce cas
aussi c'est d'avoir énormément de force
si je donne un coup de pied dedans si
jeu le perturbe qui va changer sa
dynamique et puis petit à petit il
revient quand même sur le même objet ça
je vous disais qu'on le retrouve en nous
séparant de ce qui se passe quand on va
faire un électrochoc cardiaque
on va donner un énorme coup dans le
système et c'est tellement robuste que
ça va revenir sur son cycle c'est aussi
plus cyniquement ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une bonne petite guerre quand on
est tous désynchronisée on donne un coup
de pied dedans mais on va revenir
ensemble
on trouve ce mécanisme qui mélange force
et fragilité
autour de nous dans un tas de sable par
exemple ce tas de sable il à son
équilibre il a sa forme et de temps en
temps on va poser un petit grain fragile
dessus qui va tomber régulièrement de
temps en temps ce petit grain de la
déclencher une toute petite avalanche de
temps en temps il va provoquer une
catastrophe une grande avalanche de
notre point de vue on va chercher un
responsable envie aux petits grains il
déclenche des catastrophes
en réalité la catastrophe elle est déjà
présente dans le tas de sable c'est
parce qu'il allait déjà en déséquilibre
il ya quoi elles servent ces petites
catastrophes ces petites avalanche
justement à maintenir l'équilibré du tas
de sable si on les empêche
nota de salva monte monte monte monte
jusqu'à une véritable catastrophe
les petits incidents sont fréquents
servent à l' équilibre et les grands
sont rares et mènent à des explosions
prenons l'exemple d'un volcan s'il y a
des petites fuites
il va trouver son équilibre si je veux
absolument le contrôler je le bush et là
on à l'explosion
donc à vouloir éviter ces petits
incidents qui finalement nous réguler
nous organise on va peut-être vers des
catastrophes
le cerveau fonctionne selon ces deux
principes c'est un set un tas de sable
d'une certaine façon il reçoit des
petits grains de sable c'est la
perception c'est tout ce que vous
recevez par les yeux par les oreilles
partout vos nerfs ça vient nous
perturber sa bien déclencher des
avalanches ne faut pas avoir peur des
avalanches ce sont nos idées c'est ce
moment où justement il y à une
organisation qui se met en place dans
tous nos neurones en même temps
simplement sur une petite évocation est
sacrée notre univers mental on peut voir
ça en regardant l'activité juste au
cours du temps d'un neurone
elle est chaotique aussi c'est en nous
et si on en prend plusieurs camps les
regarde évolué au cours du temps et
l'expérience a été faite en 87
et qu'on présente une odeur inconnu
c'était sur un lapin et qu'on lui
présente une odeur inconnu d'un seul
coup ça devient plus nerveux
tout simplement parce que je ne connais
pas il faut que j'explore il faut que
j'aille plus loin dans ma connaissance
si par contre je présente à ce cher
lapin une odeur connu s'est organisée on
va avoir le chaos qui va un petit peu
diminué l'avalanche va être un petit peu
plus belle - moi désordonnée alors vous
allez me dire oui c'est très bien ce
chaos cette fragilité et on a quand même
des connaissances on sait que deux plus
deux ça fait 4 on sait que le ciel est
bleu en sait des choses sur le monde qui
sont dès qu'ils sont devenus des
certitudes faut considérer que ces
éléments là parce que nos cerveaux va
fonctionner de la même façon ce sont
comme les autoroutes de penser ce sont
des raccourcis on va passer d'un point à
un autre
dans notre dynamique cérébrale et c'est
un petit peu comme des couloirs
d'avalanche je parlais d'avalanche tout
à l'heure à force de les pratiquer à
force avoir récité nos tables de
multiplication et bien tout de suite on
a deux fois 3 6 on y arrive tout de
suite on a un couloir d'avalanche
parce que l'apprentissage justement
permet au cerveau de tracer ses couloirs
et sa force c'est de pouvoir le faire
dans toutes les fibres et dans toute sa
complexité
donc si je vous donne une certitude
comme la somme des angles d'un triangle
fait et on l'a appris on la ressasser
180 degrés c'est un automatisme et on
peut continuer sauf que sur une sphère
ce n'est pas le cas on peut avoir un
triangle à trois angles droits
donc le fait de rentrer et
automatiquement dans ses couloirs
d'avalanche ça créé des automatismes de
pensée qui nous font passer à côté
peut-être de connaissances importantes
et c'est comme quand on prend une
autoroute pour atteindre sa destination
il faut en sortir et c'est peut-être ça
ce qu'on peut appeler cette serendipity
c'est le fait qu'avec des accidents que
ça ne correspond pas exactement à nos
autoroutes de penser c'est qu'on
découvre quelque chose qu'on n'avait pas
prévu et ça c'est un entraînement c'est
justement de sortir de ses certitudes de
faire confiance à son intuition et ceci
a été montré de façon absolue en 1931
par un mathématicien
faisons donc quelques petites
expériences sur le cerveau on va
simplifier le cerveau et on va
considérer que ce sont des petits
éléments en interaction il s'envoie des
petits grains de sable qui vont le
perturber prenons une personne qui a des
sens qui va recevoir de l'information et
qui va donc par le nez on va recevoir
des molécules qui vont activer comme ça
a déclenché des petites avalanche par
les oreilles ce sont des vibrations
sonores qui vont sur vos tympans par les
yeux ce sont des vibrations magnétique
d'être magnétique par votre main ce sont
les pressions qu'ils vont déclencher de
la chimie et qu'ils vont envoyer tous
ces petits grains de sable à votre
cerveau et on les voit qui apparaissent
pas et qui vont le stimuler lui il a une
envie c'est d'être dans sa dynamique
dans son mode de fonctionnement donc
percevoir percevoir c'est reconstruire
en permanence en temps et en espace en
temps parce que quand vous reconnaissez
une musique que vous connaissez je vais
pas vous l'a sifflé mais c'est parce que
si elle s'arrête vous pouvez la
continuer dans l'instant présent
les avalanches qui se déclenche chez
vous en déclenché d'autres qui vous
permettent de vous dire ah oui je sais
je sais où ça va et c'est vraiment ce
que va faire le cerveau être ancré dans
l'instant présent et imaginer comment ça
va se passer dans le futur
cette tomate par exemple que vous avez
reconnu vous n'en avez pas fait
l'expérience mais je suis persuadé que
vous pouvez imaginer ce qu'il ya
derrière
vous le savez votre cerveau le
reconstruit il n'est pas que face à une
image
il est face à toutes les associations
possibles au niveau de vos neurones de
tous les expériences que vous avez fait
avec le concept de tomates et c'est un
apprentissage fondamental dans le
cerveau c'est que lorsque deux neurones
sont actifs en même temps ils renforcent
leurs liens
comme on est dans un monde où la tomate
ne se présente jamais tout le temps de
la même façon jamais du même côté jamais
dans la même barque est que tout n'est
pas organisé de façon certaine des
tomates il y en a même une seule tomate
dct en fonction de l'orientation ce
n'est pas la même
ça permet comme j'ai associé l'activité
de mes neurones 2 à 2 partout les
expériences que j'ai fait que s'ils
manquent un boudin formation il va
reconstruire
autre donc c'est tomates vous pouvez
voir le dos vous savez à peu près
commencer vous pouvez même penser à ce
qui se passe dehors vous pouvez leur
pensée le reconstruire vous êtes un
instant présent vraiment dans votre
univers en train de reconstruire toutes
les parties on veut expérimenter la
sensibilité du chaos
quel est le visage masculin quel est le
visage féminin en général les personnes
me disent que le visage féminin est à
gauche il n'y a pas de différence entre
ces deux images sinon un très léger
contraste si on lâche votre perception à
peu près au même endroit
votre cerveau il a appris à séparer
toutes ses fibres à les analyser et à
dire ça ça correspond à t-elle couloirs
d'avalanche et celui ci à tel autre
le côté attracteur qui a réussi à ne pas
lire le mot chant c'est impossible
vos neurones vont se synchroniser
automatiquement ils vont immédiatement
allé dans ce couloir d'avalanche la
robustesse
tout à l'heure on l'a vu on peut lâcher
à plein de points différents et on
arrive au même concept là léa il y en a
plein ici votre cerveau va chercher
qu'est ce qui fait la différence
et ben oui on l'a tous vu la petite
mouche sur la bouche même souvent en
premier parce que leur est ok on sait
mais ça c'est important c'est un petit
peu différent c'est une fille sur
laquelle j'ai quelque chose à apprendre
qui est caractéristique de cette
personne
tout ce que je vous ai présenté ça
marche au niveau des neurones et du
réseau ça marche aussi dans les réseaux
humains c'est la même chose c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'intelligence en réseau
ou l'intelligence collective réussir à
créer du lien 2 à 2 simplement parce
qu'on est synchrone pour ça il faut
partager il faut expérimenter il faut
ouvrir ces territoires
il faut repenser justement ces modes de
fonctionnement ensemble dans notre
société
et si on y arrive un exemple
l'intelligence collective ce sont les
nuées d'oiseaux qui arrivent à éviter
les obstacles sans qu'il y ait de chef
et qui maintiennent leur structure par
des petits incidents parfois et pour
éviter comme ça des catastrophes et je
vous disais voilà je l'embrassé le chaos
mais bon bras sont le monde tous
ensemble acceptons cette fragilité est
cette force qui est en nous n'essayons
pas de la combattre comme venture de
désordre qui vient de l'extérieur donc
pour ça soyez sensible
c'est véritablement votre force
n'hésitez pas à les incidents sinon à ce
cumul et ça va devenir une véritable
catastrophe
vive l instant présent c'est là où est
situé le cerveau c'est là qu'il reçoit
les choses douter de vos certitudes vous
prenez des autoroutes
sortez des sentiers battus utilisez-le
en vie quand vous avez une envie c'est
que le cerveau est en train de se
projeter dessus construisez le futur et
les curiosités sans nostalgie n'essayez
pas de le figer partager collaborer
accompagné dit oui et pouvaient
l'évidence ne vous jugez pas les uns les
autres
d'une certaine façon c'est ce qu'on
appelle le lâcher prise certains vont
dire ouais mais quel est le problème
avec tout ça qu'elle d'un quelqu'un
ouvre justement ils vont dire qu'il va
faire tout cadré et ou hiérarchiser tout
organisé et ainsi de suite
moi je vous laisse choisir si on cadre
tout on va peut-être vers la catastrophe
et de s'embraser
au lieu de s'embrasser merci